Sera's with us in Los Angeles hi Sarah
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thanks for having me on certainly how
can I help so my husband and I are
wanting to buy our first house we've
moved a lot over the years so we have
rented but now we're ready to settle
down and we're trying to decide between
buying an existing house or building one
okay I'm sorry go ahead building a house
is two things number one you're gonna
pay the top of the market per square
foot used housing is always cheaper per
square foot you get more bang for your
buck with used housing always okay so if
you can get a nice home that is in good
shape that is used you will get more
house for the money so that's one
benefit of going that way the other
thing is building a house can cause a
divorce that's what we've heard yeah
it's a complete pain in the butt I mean
I'm a project manager mindset and I grew
up around the building business and I
used to sell new construction so it's
pretty easy for me to build a house
because I'm just deaf on a budget a plan
and a timeline and I ride everybody's
butt to get all three of those things to
hit but if you're not gonna including my
wife to get the fixtures picked out
right and on budget on time and that fit
the plan and so you know and yet I don't
care what the decorator says we're doing
it this way and so you've got to have
somebody in there that's doing that and
if otherwise the two of you're just
gonna fight about everything the other
problem is sometimes people when they're
building a house they think they're
building a dream house and by the time
you get the stupid thing built your
dream changes so it's not really your
dream house there's no such thing it's a
house so there's some benefits to moving
into a new house it's fun I mean the
last two houses we did we built them the
one we live in now in our lake house we
built both of them and you know it's
wonderful you got all new stuff all the
new technology all that stuff that's
kind of cool but you know it is a it's a
stressful
process and it's not gonna be it's not
ever gonna be perfect
none of them are there a house right
right so if you want to have fun with it
and enjoy the journey and manage a
project and pay a little bit more what
you'll get is all the new stuff and get
everything exactly like you want it
right now
warning spoiler alert five years from
now you'll redecorate anyway because
that color of orange just doesn't work
anymore that's I might have heard that
in my house it could have happened so
you're gonna you're gonna repaint you're
gonna do stuff that you know stuff wears
out you put a new roof on someday it's a
house it deteriorates and it changes and
so just you know it's only gonna be like
really really cool and perfect for maybe
a year and a half and it's not even
gonna be perfect then still gonna be
crap that's broke you're gonna do punch
list and out your ears with the Builder
it's just how the process works so if
you'll have your your expectation set
like that and not worship at the altar
of the house and think that this house
is going to bring you great joy then
you'll probably actually have fun doing
it I actually enjoy building a house but
but I don't worship the house it's just
a stupid house so it's fun to make sure
stuff you know to control the
controllables and project manage the
thing it's just how my brain works so if
you wanna do all that a little bit more
you'll get a cool if you'll have a cool
thing that's fine there's no downside to
either one you're gonna come out okay
either way it's not you're gonna pay 30%
more for new housing or you shouldn't
anyway unless somebody's got some scam
running but it is gonna be a good five
to ten percent more than use housing per
square foot so it's a cool it's a cool
adventure but just have proper
perspective as you go into it three
things to always do when you're building
a house three pieces of paper and you
manage the project with those three
pieces of paper the blueprint which
tells you what everybody's doing and
everybody's in agreement on what we're
doing the budget which tells you what
everybody's doing and everybody's in
agreement on what we're doing we're
spending this on the carpet we're
spending that on the light fixtures
period and the schedule a detailed
schedule from your builder as to when
they're going to deliver this product
and then everyone understands that if
that sub doesn't show up we are behind
and everyone understands that we're not
putting $20,000 worth of carpet in that
room we have $8,000 budgeted for it I
don't care how pretty it is this is the
budget this is the blueprint this is the
schedule manage to those three pieces of
paper and don't worship it and you'll
have a blast cool fun stuff thanks for
calling in